안녕하세요 비자남입니다 제가 오늘
드디어 뉴욕으로 출장을 갑니다
여러분들 제가 뉴욕 가서 재미난 영상
중 많이 촬영할 예정이니까
관심있게 봐주시면 좋을 것 같습니다
가시죠
[음악]
mou를 할
업체를 만나기 위해서는
체크인 하자마자 나왔습니다
[음악]
박진우 부사장님 모셔서 뉴욕의 집을
한번 좀 보여드리도록 하겠습니다
없어요 안녕하세요
지금 우리가 볼 집은 지금
어떤 집인지 소개 좀 해주시겠어요
여기 주소는
떨이나인 웨스트 23가 정확한
주소고요 23가에 위치해 있는
플레라이언 하우스입니다
투베드룸 기준으로
약 한 330에서 350만 불 정도
하는데
렌트는
12,000불에서 14,000 불
정도
뉴욕에서 평균적으로 봤을 때는 가격이
어느 정도 아주 아주 높은 지역은
아니지만 그래도
탑
5% 정도는 길 것 같아요 이쪽에
좋은 지역에 위치해 있고
새로 지은 빌딩에 좋은 시설을
이용하고자 하는 테넌트분들은 이런
빌딩들을 없어서 못 찾고 계시죠
과연 뉴욕에 14,000불에
투 베드룸
과연 어떻게 생겼는지 내부가 좀
궁금한데 한번 들어가서 보도록
하겠습니다 가시죠 여기는 이렇게
라운지 식으로 만들어서 사람들이 좀
실수도 있고요 영화도
볼 수 있고 여기에 이제
탁구대가 설치되어 있었는데 지금 약간
보수를 하고 있는 거 같아요
[음악]
여기가 이제이
빌딩의 가장 전형적인
투배들
인데요
[박수]
[음악]
여기가 이제
왕복 6차선이 되다 보니까
앞에 좀 빌딩이 있어도 개방감이 좀
있어요 거실이 정도면 넓네요 저희가
이제 투자자분을 대지해서 이제
임대료를 드릴 때는 저희 이제
사진사가 3D 촬영을 싹 해서 가구를
입체적으로 입히는 사진은 저희가
만들어내요 그래서 그렇게 해서 임대를
놀 수 있게끔 하죠
특이하게 주방하고 약간
리빙룸을 이렇게
분절 해놓은
스타일인데 여기도 좀 호불호가
있습니다 좋아하시는 분들도 계시고
와이프는
스타일이네요
맨하탄에서는 사실
계산을 해보면
투자금 대비 수익률이 2.5%를
넘는 경우가 좀 거의 없다고 보시면
돼요 다만 여기는 시간이 지나면서
계속 가치가 상승을 하는 부분이니까
투자를 하실 때는 아무래도 좋은
지역에 좋은
신규 건물에 그 황금성이 좋은 곳을
하시는게
훨씬 더
맞다라고 저는 생각이 듭니다
[음악]
맨
하탄 북쪽에 윌리엄스버거 뭐였지요이
블루클린과 유나타운 브릿지 사이에
사진 찍는
것을
포인트라는 콤보하고 그 옆에 있는
군데를 보고
정보를 한번 가서 사진을
찍으시고
[음악]
[박수]
부족하고 브루클린의 프라임이 있는
지역하고는 일단 지역에 따른 차이가
좀 확실하게 나고요 시장의 가격을
리딩하는 거는 맨하탄이에요 그래서
맨하탄에서 가격을 끌어 올려주면
브루클린이 키를 맞춰가는 형태이고요
또 한국분들도 많이 아시는
롱아일랜드 시티 엘시티라고 하는
동네에도 사실 좋은 콘도들이 많이
들어갔지만 가격이 브루클린하고 좀
비슷하게 형성이 되어 있고
맨하탄에서 앞에서 끌어주고 두 개
지역들이 따라가는 형태이기 때문에
지금 현 시점에서는
브루클린이 예전보다 많이 올라와 있고
맨하탄은 올라간 상태에서 좀 정체가
되어 있었기 때문에 사실은 지금의
시점에서 보면은
맨하탄 지역에 투자하시는 부분이 훨씬
더
맞다라고 저는 판단하고 있습니다
한국분들이 이제 뉴욕에 있는 부동산을
만
약에 한다라고 했을 때
관리에 대한 부분이 되게 좀 궁금해
하실 것 같아요 저희는 이제 저희를
통해서 매입을 하시는 고객분들한테는
첫해에는 저희가 무상으로 관리를 해
드리고요네
첫해에는
둘째부터는 저희가
렌트 인컴의 일정부분 퍼센트를 높지
않게 적용을 해서 그거에 대해서
매니지먼트를 해 드리는데
현재 임차인이 나가고
새로운 임차인이 들어왔을 때 그
들어오는 기간 동안에 유닛을 재정비를
해야 된다거나 아니면
기존에 살던 테넌트가
어떤 문제를 일으켰던 것들을 또 이제
해결을 해야 된다거나 이런 부분들이
사실은
매니지먼트 경험이 많지 않은 분들이
하기에는 좀 쉽지 않은 부분들이
있어요 저희한테 맡기시면은 사실 좀
큰 걱정 없이 자산관리를 해 드리기
때문에 저희를 찾으시는 분들이 그런
부분에서는 되게 좀 좋아하시는 거
같습니다 만약에 이제 뉴욕의
방문하시는 분이 계신다면 저희 그
박진우 부사장님한테 한번 연락을 해서
보면서 느끼는 점들이 좀 많거든요
만약에 영상을 보시고 만약에 뉴욕
부동산 에 관심 있다라고 하시면은
한번 문의를 하셔서 좀 이렇게 비교도
하면서 보시면 좋을 거 같습니다 오늘
영상이 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다
[음악]